この新卒採用で大切にしなければならない
ものこう事業の価値に共感して入社をした
のかそれとも自分自身のこうキャリアを
うんうん獲得するきっかけにしたいと思っ
て入社しているのかっていう本質的に価値
観に合ってる人をうん取り続け
るっていうことをやろうとしたらうん
やっぱりそういったお客様の視点であっ
たり働く仲間の視点で見た時に本当にその
人が一緒にやるべき仲間なのか
え弊社の新卒からえ取締役管理ホム部長に
ですねえしっかりえのし上がってきた
まさにあのえキングダムのようにですね大
将軍になるぞということでえ上に上がって
きましたえ取締役新卒初の取締役高橋優也
というですねま私が最も今信頼を寄せて
いるえ人材の1人ですけれども今回紹介さ
せていただきます対談楽しんでくださいえ
高橋ゆと申しますえ2007年に新卒採用
でアチーブメント株式会社には入社をさせ
ていただきましてえ今18年目になります
え入社当時はですねま人事部からえ配属を
受けましてえ人事の仕事をさせていただき
ながらま採用やま育成っていうところに
携わりながらですねえ少しずつ経営管理
本部のま仕事をえん担当するようになり
ましてうんま今ですねえ取締系管理本部長
というところになりますのでまいわゆる
営業部門以外ですねえ警管理部門に対して
のえ管轄ということでやらせていただいて
おりますうんちょっと硬いんじゃないの
もうちょっと柔らかいはい
はい彼はですね実はあのキリマジロにです
ねたった1人でえ単独東長えやしまして実
はあのになったというちょっとあの
キャリアがあるんですけどちょっとあの人
隣を知ってもらう上でねはいまずあの稲田
出て色々選べる選択肢がある中でなんで
まずアチーブメントに入ってそしてなん
だろうそのねまさに今頂点の道というか
山登りを会社の中でもなんかしてる感じが
するんだけどもえその辺のところちょっと
自分なりになぜアチーブメントを選んだの
かもちょっと話してもらえる本当に社会の
ためになる仕事をやりたいなっていう
気持ちがあってま首相活動していましたま
色々経営者さんの話をよくこう聞きに行っ
てたっていうえ人間でしたねうんでそう
いう中で出会ったのが実はま
アチーブメントでありまき長だったという
まそういう経緯ですねはいうんうん
[音楽]
うんまアチーブメントも20年間深層左右
に取り組んできたんだけれどもやっぱり
こう入る人間もいるけれどもえ全員がっ
てるわけじゃないねやっぱり離職もあった
でも高橋君はある時僕にえ辞める人の
気持ちが分からないとなんで自分自身が
選んだその会社でその選択をなんで正解に
しないのか自分はやっぱりえ選んだ以上は
ここで自分の使命全するんだと辞める人の
気持ちがわかんないって言ったことがある
んだけどもま自分のの中で今確信を持っ
てることやその新卒採用にえ対するこう
思いみたいなものそんなものをちょっと
話してもらえるはい入社してから最初の3
年間ぐらいでえま先輩たちの中でも退職さ
れるような方々もまいらっしゃいました
うんうんうんで事実そういった方々に
向き合っていく中でもま本当にこの会社が
やっているうんうんこう事業の価値に共感
して入社をしたのかうんうん
それとも何かその自分の成長だとかそのま
きっかけというかうんうんうん自分自身の
こうキャリアをうんうん獲得するきっかけ
にしたいと思って入社しているのかって
いうことの違いがうんますごく大きいん
じゃないかなっていう風に思いましてうん
うんうんまそこからよりこの会社の事業の
価値っていうものに本当に共感した人材を
ま採用しようっていうことを決めてですね
うんうんうんま採用活動に取り組んだって
いうものはうんうんありますしうんま会社
自体のやっぱり採用基準っていうものが
非常に大事なんだなっていうことをうん
うんうん最初の段階で学びましたね
なるほどなるほど
ま僕はこの会社を創業してから今までまあ
37年間全く変わらないものがあるとし
たらパーパス目的なんだよねまこの社会の
おま最大の社会課題とも言える不満足な
人間関係が起因するあらゆる不幸をま撲滅
したいとま大げさにねちょっと表現をする
けれどもやっぱ軽減をしていきたいだこの
問題を解決できるやはりま研修事業教育
ですよねま人材教育というものを私はま
事業としてま起こしたわけです
よちょうどゆ君入った時って社員何名
ぐらいだったちょうど50名を超えた
タイミングだったと思いますうんま今正社
員は220人になったんだけどねこの新卒
採用で大切にしなければならないもの
どんなことを1番大事にしなけばいけない
という風にま責任者として感じてますか記
者長が最後に役員面接でもま必ず判断基準
として確認してることだと思うんです
けれどもま1つはやっぱりその自分がもし
お客様だったとし
たらそのコンサルタントにこう担当して
もらいたいのかっていう判断基準で見た時
にうんま本当にその人を採用するべきなの
かっていうま視点がこう生まれてきたり
うんままた我々の会社自体がやっぱ全社員
で三角型の採用をやってるっていうことの
意味もつながると思うんですけれども
うんうんやっぱり仲間がうん一緒に働き
たいという風にうんこう本100%
そえるかどうかうんまこれはやっぱり本質
的に重要なんじゃないかなとつまり採用
自体のやっぱり目標やもちろんその計画
っていうのはあるんですけれども最終的に
本質的に価値観にあってる人をうんうん
取り続けるっていうことをやろうとしたら
うんやっぱりそういったお客様の視点で
あったり働く仲間の視点で見た時に本当に
その人が一緒にやるべき仲間なのかって
いうことがま何か見えてくるようなます
ねま実際のところね人事の責任者で例えば
報酬を決定するシーンだとかまいろんな
そのフェアネスアチーブメントすごく大事
にしている精神とかまあると思うんだ
けれどもやっぱりこう役員になって見えて
きたものもあるでしょうそれまで見え
なかったもの我々の会社だと前半年ごとに
ま報酬改定がありますよねでその中でま
社員のいわゆるその報酬の昇級学のま一覧
表っていうのをま私の方でま会社のその
制度に乗ってま作りますよねまそれをき
社長にまお見せするま最後決済を取
るっていま確認をするっていうま時間が
あると思うんですけれどもやっぱりそこで
ま毎回こう私自身も感じることっていうの
はもちろん会社のルールとしてのフェア
さっていうものがあってまそのルールに
乗っ取って従ってもちろんその小給学を
決めたりうんうんま本人のいわゆる
プロモーション小心昇格を決めたりって
いうことはましていくんですけれどもうん
やっぱり最後のこの意思決定決済のところ
でやっぱ常にアキ長がおっしゃっている
こていうのはうんやっぱり本当にこれで
その頑張りに対し
て1人1人のその社員の顔をちゃんと
思い浮かべた時にちゃんと報われているの
かっていうことを本当にその最後までこう
突き詰めるうんあのバイネームで彼はどう
なんだうんじゃ彼女はどうなんだっていう
風にこうやっぱりこう1人1人やっぱり
確認をその取っていくプロセスっていうの
がうんま私自身もこのアチーブメントと
いう会社がすごく好きなところでもあるん
ですけどもま先ほどのリネもありました
通りま働社員全社員のま物心両面の豊かな
うんうん人生の実現いううんまここに
やっぱり心を傾けて最後決するていですね
うんはいまこのプロセスはやっぱりまいつ
も印象的にま感じてますねはいま僕は
すごく大事にしてるのはこう尊徳の経営で
はなくねやっぱりま私は雇われ社長だと
ずっと言い続けてきたんだけど私を雇っ
てるこに人がいるとま1回も世の中に出て
きたことがなくてそのなんだ言葉も使わ
ないとただ必ず結果で示してくるし学びの
場を与えてくれるとその名前は聖は原理名
は原則さんだとま言い続けてその原理原則
に沿った経営をしていきたいと思ってま
37年心がけてきたんだけどもま要するに
なんだろうなやっぱ愛という言葉を言うの
は簡単なんだけどその愛とは何かと思言っ
た時にやっぱり僕は縁ある人を物心両面の
豊かな人生に導いていくことこれが実学
実存主義というか実学の愛だと僕は思っ
てるのねだから私はどうしたらもっと
むくれるかと考えてるんだけどそれま言う
なれば系で言うとコストを増大させること
を経営者自らが必死にやってるわけだだよ
ねでもその結果アチーブメントは発展し
続けてるんですよ僕はやっぱり喜んで
もらいたいという気持ちがすごく強いん
ですよだからま文化としてその受け継いで
もらいたい文化っていうのはそういう縁
ある人を幸せにできる経営縁ある人に喜ん
でもらえる経営本当に心から役に立っで
いるそういうなんて言うのかなそこら辺の
ところがね僕はすごく大事なことだなと
思って
ますこのメッセージを聞いていただいてる
方々には是非分かっていただきたいことは
やっぱり中心にパーパスがあ
るってことですねそして目先の尊徳では
なく採用というのは投資なんですよだから
インベストメント投資ですただそれは
なんだろうな100%報いられるかどうか
は分からないですよね未来のことはでも
自分の子供に対しても教育は投資という
ことで教育費をかけるそれは別に子供から
リターンを得ようと思うのではなくて
やっぱり子供に対する愛情それがやっぱり
教育に対する熱意を生み出すと思うんです
よやっぱり自分を大切にし自分に縁ある人
を大にするそういう意味ではまどんどん
投資をしてですねえその1人1人が成長し
てその集合隊が組織としてま工学納税法人
としても本当に私はま社会の後期として
発展していきたいなという風に思ってい
ますま高橋君霧万城では真相になったけど
ねまアーメンはいくらあの登っても死ぬ
ことはないのでねしっかりとこれからも頑
てねえやってください本当に期待してます
あなたはね誠実でそして仕事に対する真摯
さ本当にね真正面から仕事に取り組む真摯
さそして卓越した責任感を持っています
信頼していますあなたを役員にして良かっ
たと思ってるしま新卒のある意味では
モデル社員として管理部門のこれからね卒
もしとこれからして会社の未来を作って
もらいたいと思います今日はありがとう
感謝しますありがとうございます